[Applauso]
non ho mai avuto il sogno di diventare
un'attrice
la mia passione per il cinema è iniziata
per caso
mia zia anni fa mi portò a fare un
provino per delle comparsate in a
giambra il secondo film di jonas
carpignano
da lì jonas michel se poi per una
piccola scena ma io non sapevo che
quello sarebbe stato un inizio di tutto
dopo un paio di anni gianassi mi propose
diventare la protagonista del suo
prossimo film a chiara
ero talmente spaventata che rifiutai
e chiaro che ho avuto una reazione
troppo esagerata tutto questo perché
pensavo di non essere capace
era una responsabilità che non volevo
prendermi forse perché non ho mai avuto
una grande autostima di me stessa
a 15 anni sia ancora troppo piccoli per
capire l'importanza delle cose come
quando in terza media ci viene imposto
di scegliere la scuola che dovremmo fare
per i prossimi cinque anni in
prospettiva del lavoro che vorremmo fare
io ho avuto molte difficoltà a scegliere
perché non sapevo cosa realmente mi
appassionasse ora che 17 anni e sono al
penultimo anno ho capito che non bisogna
seguire una traiettoria ben precisa come
volte ci disegnano ma che anzi ogni
esperienza sbagliata giusta che sia può
segnarci e insegnarci
il mio percorso scolastico non sembri
centrare con quello che poi vorrò fare
però so che quello che sto studiando
entra a far parte del mio bagaglio
culturale
bisogna conoscere sempre tutto quello
che ci viene proposto per avere libertà
di scegliere il nostro futuro
meno conosciamo e meno potremo scegliere
quindi non vi abbattete se ciò che
studiate non mi piace mi sembra inutile
mi servirà sicuramente per decidere cosa
vorrete o non vorrete fare
ero convinta che il cinema o recitare
fosse qualcosa di irraggiungibile
lontano da me ma evidentemente mi
sbagliavo
oggi sto ricevendo importanti
riconoscimenti che andranno a segnare
per sempre il mio percorso lavorativo
universitario ma soprattutto personale
io voglio raccontare la mia storia per
testimoniarvi che qualsiasi incontro o
qualsiasi passione può avere un grande
impatto su di voi
io per esempio incontrato il cinema che
ha avuto ha avuto la capacità di
insegnarmi la capacità comunicativa che
prima non avevo in primo luogo con jonas
il giorno per giorno parlavamo
approfonditamente sulle scene ho
imparato ad aprirmi al livello più
personale con la mia famiglia anch'essa
parte del film con cui avuto dei
dialoghi molto intimi che mi hanno fatto
a crescere e soprattutto mi hanno fatto
capire come rapportarmi con loro la
magia della troupe parlare con persone
che arrivano da ogni parte del mondo che
hanno lingue e culture diverse dalla mia
ma quando mi chiedevano cosa vorresti
fare da grande
rimanevo immobili a pensare avevo
miliardi di cose che mi passano per la
testa
ma la verità è che in età adolescenziale
nessuno pensa al lavoro una ragazzina di
15 anni pensa a uscire con gli amici
andare a scuola ma soprattutto pensa a
godersi i propri momenti adolescenziali
e invece mi sono ritrovato a gestire
scuola e lavoro ritmi errori diversi
pensate una ragazzina che non capì che
non capiva cosa stesse facendo e
soprattutto l'importanza di quello ke
stesse facendo
quella ragazzina che ha dovuto mettere
da parte i propri amici
aveva paura di perdere la perdere l'anno
per le troppe assenze fatte ma dovrò
tutto dipenderebbe momenti
poi di colfosco più una pandemia che
però ha avuto sui risvolti positivi
in quel periodo di pausa o volete un po
di riflettere molto capi che prima di
cominciare questa avventura
aveva una concezione di vita banale e
pensavo che la gratitudine fosse
qualcosa di scontato
non riusciva a trovarci un senso e forse
nemmeno ci pensavo perché troppo
impegnata a fare però non inutili
oggi invece so che le mie scelte le ho i
miei studi mi hanno aiutato a capire
dove non volevo essere
mi hanno spinto ad andare avanti a cede
qualcosa di diverso per me hanno dato un
senso a quel mio primo provino
quindi cogliete le opportunità e
sfruttate al meglio
ma torniamo ora a tre anni fa al primo
giorno di riprese
ero ansiosa un po curiosa di come
funziona su un set cinematografico è un
po spaventata voi penserete spaventata
perché se non fare qualcosa che non ho
mai fatto no ero spaventata perché
pensavo che alla gente mi avrebbero si
in giro vivendo in un piccolo paese dove
tutti fanno la stessa cosa può succedere
il giudizio degli altri ci fa male e ci
influenzano le nostre scelte ma
fortunatamente sono riuscito a placare
tutte le le sbagliate che mi frullano
per la testa e ho fatto quello che ho
dovuto fare
in quel periodo è come se avessi avuto
dei tappi nelle orecchie
mi ero in puntata che la medici si
inizia al erano e dove continua ad
essere così
fortunatamente ho sempre avuto accanto a
me persone che non sempre mi hanno
sempre consigliato senza mai obbligarmi
allontanate da voi quelle persone che
non sono in grado di aiutarvi non perché
voi abbiate sempre bisogno di consigli
ma in decisioni come queste
potreste affossare una strada che si era
aperta ma che non avete saputo
percorrere perché troppo genici
ero partita demotivata senza prospettive
positive
è convinta che non mi sarebbe piaciuto
ma dopo pochi giorni di riprese la
voglia di continuare questo film si
faceva sempre più grande
arrivai a fine film
che ho capito che non potevo farne a
meno
le ultime scene fatti sono state le più
distruttive avevo capito che quella
magia sarebbe svanita da un momento
all'altro e che forse non avrei più
incontrato con le persone con cui ormai
ce vò costruito dei rapporti
miss il mio ego da parte e amici che
comunicherà attraverso il linguaggio
cinematografico e quello che vorrò fare
questa esperienza mi portò capire che la
nostra generazione è cresciuta signora
il cassetto e pensiamo che creare dei
progetti sia qualcosa di strano ma non è
così ci ostiniamo a rimandare sempre
tutto perché convinti di avere tutto il
tempo del mondo a disposizione non
vogliamo pressione dalle famiglie e
dalla società ma rischiamo di rimanere
tali dati per la paura di non sapere
cosa scegliere
il futuro che noi crediamo sia lontano
inizia adesso
grazie
[Applauso]